[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est rien ce n'est qu'un mauvais rêve
j'ai encore entendu
et plus de cauchemars cette nuit
d'accord champion
[Musique]
ça devient ridicule
c'est une vieille maison il y a
forcément des bruits pendant la nuit
[Musique]
Peter qui a dessiné
plus de cauchemars d'accord
c'est bien
en fait j'aurais bien aimé pouvoir
parler avec quelqu'un de toutes les
choses qui se sont passées dans la
maison
[Musique]
maman
on est obligé de prendre certaines
décisions pour protéger sa famille
qu'est-ce que c'est
les petits coups
[Musique]
il n'y a aucun bruit Peter
tu as une magnifique imagination mais un
jour ça risque de te jouer des tours